[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 18 novembre
voici les titres jusqu'à dimanche c'est
la 25e semaine européenne pour l'emploi
des personnes handicapées à cette
occasion rencontre avec emilie d'élan
bas atteintes de sclérose en plaques
elle nous raconte son quotidien de
salariés invité également en plateau
josé lucas président de l'association y
es attrape
sept cent mille jeunes en seraient
victimes en france c'est la journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire à rambouillet les élèves se
saisissent du phénomène en allant
sensibiliser d'autres élèves depuis 2018
une team anti harcèlement est né au
lycée bascans l'objectif libérer la
parole
et pour motiver les jeunes dans leur
insertion professionnelle quoi de mieux
qu'une championne pour témoigner de son
parcours la médaillée de bronze aux jeux
paralympiques margot boulet a participé
à une rencontre c'était au centre
commercial westfield vélizy 2 et dans le
cadre du programme scola porté par les
apprentis d'auteuil
mais avant de développer ces titres la
nouvelle tournure dans le dossier de
l'attentât de magnanville le parquet
national anti terroriste a requis le
renvoi devant les assises d'un complice
présumé mohamed lamine à beyrouth est
soupçonné d'avoir été présent au moment
des faits son adn retrouvé sur les lieux
du crime le 13 juin 2016 un couple de
policiers jessica chesnais d'heure et
jean baptiste salvan était assassiné au
couteau à leur domicile de magnanville
en présence de leurs enfants de 3 ans le
terroriste abattu par les forces de
l'ordre se réclamait aides de l'état
islamique mohamed lamine à des rousses
de son côté clame son innocence ils
avaient été mises en examen dès 2017 et
placé en détention provisoire l'homme de
28 ans a été condamné en juin dernier
dans une autre affaire celle de la
tentative d'attentât aux bonbonnes de
gaz à paris en 2016 il a écopé de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement pour non
dénonciation de crime terroriste il
prévoit notamment l'interdiction des
animaux sauvages dans les cirques et les
delphinariums est la vente aussi de
chiots et chatons dans les animaleries
pro ib le projet de loi contre la
maltraitance animale a été adopté
définitivement ce jeudi par le parlement
avec un ultime vote du sénat le porte
parole du gouvernement gabriela talent
est venu à cette occasion dans les
yvelines aux côtés de la députée aurore
bergé qui a porté le texte au programme
visite cet après midi du refuge de la
fondation brigitte bardot installé à
bazoches sur guyonne particularité les
animaux y vivent en liberté les propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude et maxime là c'était important
de venir ici à la fondation brigitte
bardot parce que c'est grâce à la
fondation grâce aux associations que
cette loi a pu exister parce que si on
n'avait pas eu des associations qui
cependant des aînés en lutte et re vrai
on travaillait à nos côtés ont alerté
les citoyens tout simplement eh bien on
n'aurait pas pu aboutir à ce travail
législatif aller plus loin dans la
protection que nous devons aux animaux
avec des mesures très fortes sur
l'interdiction de la vente de chatons de
chiots en animalerie avec l'encadrement
drastique de la vente par internet avec
la fin des cétacés dans le delphinarium
avec la fin des animaux sauvages captif
dans les cirques avec la fin des
élevages de visons voilà des engagements
très forts qu'ils correspondent je crois
à des attentes importantes de la société
[Musique]
c'est la semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées 25e
édition de cet événement porté par
l'adapt pour mettre en lumière la
thématique faire se rencontrer aussi les
acteurs avant d'accueillir m'ont invité
je vous propose de rencontrer emilie des
landes elle est comme c'est le cas pour
100000 france est atteinte de sclérose
en plaques l'élan courtoise a été a
déclaré travailleuses en situation de
handicap comment allier justement
travail et handicap elle témoigne au
micro de justin brazey en 2006 c'est le
diagnostic tombe emilie est atteinte de
sclérose en plaques une maladie auto
immune qui impacte le système nerveux
central l'avenir professionnel est alors
un certain pour la jeune femme
j'ai apprise j'étais enfin d'un an fin
d'études donc là c'est un peu le choc et
ont souvent à tout de suite puisque ac a
longtemps
où il fait un temps on se voit tout de
suite dans un fauteuil roulant qu'on le
dit sclérose en plaques c'est toute ma
famille tout le monde pensait que
c'était fauteuil roulant dans quelques
années et donc c'est un peu compliqué de
se dire qu'est ce que j'ai bien pouvoir
faire aujourd'hui emilie à 38 ans elle
est déclarée travailleuse handicapée un
handicap invisible qui lui a valu des
remarques désagréables au sein de son
environnement professionnel des
personnes sont pas censés savoir non
plus la maladie c'est pas écrit sur
notre tête et voilà mais des personnes
qui vous disent je reprends toi va faire
une sieste et arrêtent et puis bah le ce
que j'ai eus sympathique ça arrête de
faire la fête arrête de boire quand tu
quand tu viens au travail sachant
qu'avec la sclérose en plaques il faut
encore des petites pertes d' équilibre
donc gerba si seulement mais n'en faites
juste fatigué mais voilà mais c'est au
final c'est tellement rare par rapport à
l'évolution que j'ai pu avoir et aux
personnes que j'ai pu rencontrer mais
quand ça arrive ça
enfin ça pique un peu salariés d'une
filiale de distribution d'électricité
depuis 2008 fatigue arrêt maladie ou
encore rendez vous à l'hôpital tous les
6 mois rythme sa carrière face à ces
contraintes des mesures ont été prises
pour aménager son poste jours d'absence
pour
renouveler nos documents
l'aménagement du temps de travail
là le méchant l'aménagement du poste
donc l'appareil j'avais un ergot le
siège dont le pc pour le clavier pour la
souris steira donc vraiment ils sont
vraiment très très très très au fait
très très impliqué de par son témoignage
elle espère faire changer le regard
porté sur le handicap visible et
invisible en entreprise
josé lucas est avec moi en plateau
bonsoir bonsoir le président de
l'association insertion éducation soins
elle se fixe comme objectif de mieux
répondre à l'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de handicap et
agit aussi pour l'insertion
professionnelle sociale l'éducation et
les soins elle est basée à trappes et la
us gère neuf établissements dans le
département dont les adh de la marsa 20
qui fournit à 145 personnes des postes
de travail qui étincelle et aussi à
trappes on va en parler dans un instant
à propos de l'emploi des personnes en
situation d'handicap c'est la semaine
européenne on le disait avant ce
reportage voici quelques chiffres le
chômage recule depuis 2010 est pour les
personnes en situation de handicap - à 4
5% mais il reste toujours deux fois plus
élevé par rapport au reste de la
population dans le secteur privé on est
à un taux d'emploi moyen qui est aux
alentours de 3 18% contre les des 6%
d'obligation légale ça veut dire qu'il
ya du progrès mais il reste encore du
chemin à accomplir il reste beaucoup de
chemin et c'est une évidence donc la
particularité de lézat de lancement
c'est que nous sommes plutôt sur du
handicap psychique orientale sensorielle
ça n'est pas du handicap moteur il ya ça
peut être lié met donc en fait c'est un
on a un taux de sortie dans en matière
dans le milieu ordinaire qui est très
très très très faibles qui est dans la
moyenne nationale puisque la vendetta 0
47% par exemple un parent de deux
sorties des hâte en milieu ordinaire
nous nous en sortons peu près 1 par an
c'est bien évidemment un objectif
mais ça n'est pas le seul objectif de
les appeler ça on essaie surtout
d'apporter de l'accompagnement en effet
de porter de la sécurité donc c'est vrai
que quelque part pouvoir les faire
travailler déjà l'insertion et
l'inclusion à partir de lézat dedans les
autres avec tout ce qu'on peut y faire
certes ou des détachements qui sont
faits on essaye au maximum de les
inclure dans la société de leur donner
une vision de la société l'an dernier au
sial et c'est vrai que c'est sous cette
forme qu'on arrive à travailler
l'inclusion au milieu alors dans le
milieu ordinaire oui mais il reste dans
un milieu protégé avec une structure qui
permet de les accompagner ça leur
apporte une autonomie qui est une
autonomie et ça leur apporte surtout
aussi une sécurité
alors il ya quand même des grands
changements qui vont qui vont intervenir
il ya une nouvelle réforme des esat a
jusqu'à présent il faut savoir que quand
on sortait d'un esat on ne pouvait pas y
revenir donc là chez une personne en
situation de handicap même si elle a
limited pouvait le faire la lâcher comme
ça dans la pas dans la nature mais hélas
lui dire voilà maintenant d'ordinaire tu
peux faire le problème c'est qu'on a un
taux d'échec derrière donc jusqu'à
présent on ne pouvait pas les reprendre
il ya plein de 2,2 points qui ont été
discutés donc avec le ministère de la
santé avec les associations et à partir
de janvier 2022 nous ont plein de choses
qui vont se mettre en place et notamment
un droit du retour et ce droit au retour
cirque on regroupe pourra reprendre on
suivra en permanence bien qu'il sera
dans milieu ordinaire on suivra le
travailleur mais on pourra le reprendre
c'est une sécurité qu'on n'avait pas
auparavant et qui doit permettre cent
ans on va passer à 30% dallas
d'inclusion dans nature d'hier tout de
suite hein c'est une évidence ça doit
permettre de faire passer quelques
personnes avec cette sécurité de savoir
qu'ils peuvent revenir alors sur cette
thématique aussi il ya le plan france
relance de 100 milliards d'euros qui a
mis en place une aide pour les
entreprises et pour soutenir justement
l'embauchent de personnes en situation
d'handicap elle est prolongée jusqu'au
31 décembre cette aide c'est une aide de
4000 euros 85 millions d'euros au total
sont concernés pour ce volet du plan ça
un premier pas intéressant il faut
gagner le droit il faut le lendemain
puis bien évidemment quand on veut quand
un travailleur handicapé peut passer
dans le milieu ordinaire qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un suivi derrière et il faut
qu'il ya un employeur qui puisse se
doter des moyens d'une structure pour
l'accompagner si vous le laissez comme
un travailleur tout à fait tout à fait
ordinaire quelque part ce n'est pas soit
il ne peut y avoir un problème donc j'ai
fait problème qui le voyait qu'il faut
absolument éviter et il faut donner les
moyens aux employeurs justement pour
pouvoir se doter d'une petite structure
d'accompagnement d'un pôle qui pourra
suivre un petit peu ces personnes en
situation de handicap et surtout ne pas
leur demander systématiquement le même
rendement que pourrait demander à
quelqu'un de valide alors une enquête
récente de l'ifop révèle que les jeunes
en situation de handicap ont été encore
plus frappés par la crise sanitaire avec
un temps de recherche d'emploi qui s'est
considérablement allongée si bien que
six jeunes sur dix aujourd'hui ne
préfère pas mentionner leur handicap sur
le cv est ce que vous observez aussi à
l'échelle de votre association d une
jeunesse plus touchés une jeunesse plus
touchés
non non on ne voit pas vraiment puisque
en fait aller ce sont les jeunes qui
peuvent plus facilement sortir en milieu
ordinaire donc bien évidemment c'est
cela qu'on va pouvoir faire sortir et
par les personnes qui ont 50 ans donc à
la limite nous on le voit un petit peu
moins et nous c'est de là l'objectif
pour nous surtout c'est pouvoir les
accompagner avec une structure les
autres qui leur permet de rentrer dans
une famille ordinaire je lui ai toujours
là pour les accompagner par les
détachements on a fait travailler
énormément en entreprise ils partent pas
par groupes ils sont complètement
autonome par petits groupes et je pense
que ça marche très très bien c'est une
première inclusion c'est pas le milieu
ordinaire définitif mais ça leur permet
d'avoir toujours ce lien social et de
voir un petit peu la réalité en fait du
monde du travail 1 les aides qui a été
créée en
1979 si j'ai pas de bêtises 40 ans plus
de 40 ans on a fêté les quarante ans en
2019 sur sur quels secteurs quelles sont
les activités professionnelles et aux
données sont assez classiques pour un
esat c'est à dire que vous avez donc
toute la partie espaces verts espaces
verts n'y a pas de tous les arts
l'espace vert blanchisserie un gros
service restauration on nous avons
ouvert à tout récemment donc un
restaurant à trappes juste à côté de la
mairie donc que tout le monde est invité
à venir déjeuner aux 12h à trappes c'est
donc un resteront peu est animé donc par
des travailleurs en situation de
handicap ça marche très très bien je
requiers au tour sont très très bons
donc au delà de blanchisserie espaces
verts espaces verts et restauration nous
avons aussi de la sous traitance quelque
chose d'assez d'assez classique de la
décoration florale voilà ce genre
d'activités tout à fait qu'ils peuvent
être qu'ils peuvent donner du travail
s'il ya une vraie différence entre avant
leur venue à lézat très évident vous
sortez s'il n'y avait pas les esat il
faut savoir que on aurait une grosse
partie des personnes en situation
d'handicap qui serait au domicile sans
activité là on a quand même dont la
porte un lien social en apporte un
accompagnement on apporte un travail et
c'est vrai que et on apporte un salaire
c'est vrai que c'est pas uniquement
l'achat ya une partie qui est le salaire
qui est payé par les autres donc pour le
travailleur c'est déjà une entrée une
petite entrée dans la vie ordinaire et
c'est déjà un grand point pour nous mais
pour plus d'informations sur
l'association j'ai vu que le site
internet s'était affichée en retrouve et
bien sûr toutes les infos sur le lien
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
josé l'ucad est revenu en plateau il
rappelle vous êtes le président de la rs
association insertion éducation soins
le 3 décembre ce sera la journée
mondiale du handicap à cette occasion
les géomètres-experts de france se
mobilisent ils lancent l'opération blue
parking l'objectif c'est de géo
localiser avec précision les places de
stationnement pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite célia gars de son go
patrick jacques de dixmude et maxime là
sur la place de l'église saint-pierre à
plaisir un géomètre expert est en train
de prendre les mesures de sept places de
parking pour personnes à mobilité
réduite
tous les géomètres experts de france
mesure de la même façon on va faire une
première mesure en fait à l'extérieur
des places où on rentre un code pour
préciser que cette mesure c'est une
mesure à l'extérieur de la place dont on
comprend une première mesure en tout pas
moins de six mesures vont être prises
les quatre coins de la place un point à
l'extérieur et le prend d'entrée de la
place les 1800 géomètre expert français
organise l'opération nationale blue
parking à l'occasion de la journée
mondiale que handicap vendredi 3
décembre le but relever les places pmr
avec une précision centimétrique pour
faciliter ensuite le stationnement des
prochaines voitures autonomes et ainsi
rendre plus simple le quotidien des
personnes handicapées l'étape suivante
en fait nous on va récupérer notre
fichier sur ordinateur et on va le
transmettre en fait au site j'ai au
foncier point fr donc un site qui est
gérée par leur des géomètres experts
dans lequel ils vont intégrer toutes les
places sur le site pour qu'ensuite ça
soit diffusé en open data et que tout le
monde puisse y avoir accès il faut à peu
près dix minutes pour prendre les
mesures d'une place le métier de
géomètre expert est encore méconnu il
regroupe plusieurs domaines d'activités
fait du bornage on délimite les
propriétés ont fait des relevés
topographiques ont fait des relevés des
architectures ont fait des relevés
des copropriétés des romans c'est très
varié on travaille sur le terrain bien
sûr en informatique dans les yvelines
seulement 30 géomètres experts sont en
activité il manquerait sur le territoire
national plus de 4000 assistant
technicien technicien ou encore
ingénieur
[Musique]
ce jeudi c'était également la journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire un fléau qui touche 6 à 10 %
des jeunes en france selon un rapport du
sénat publié en octobre dernier dans les
yvelines les établissements multiplie
les initiatives à rambouillet on peut
citer celle ci le lycée basque ans qui
est dotée désormais d'une team anti
harcèlement qui est composé d'élèves et
de membres de l'établissement mélanie
poker est allé à leur rencontre la
conséquence
à rambouillet les élèves parlent aux
élèves de boue des lycéens à 6 des
collégiens la team anti harcèlement du
lycée bascans intervient ce mercredi au
collège voisin le public ciblé les 6e
il faut pas le garder pour soi même
parce que ça pourrait aggraver encore
plus la situation c'est aussi une
richesse pour nous que d'avoir des
lycéens pour certains qui sont d'anciens
élèves du collège puisque la parole est
souvent plus facile entre pères et du
coup entre élèves même s'il ya une
petite différence d'âge
des temps théorique mais aussi plus
ludique les membres de la team créé des
jeux pour partager les notions liées aux
harcèlements et créer une relation de
confiance des personnes qui vont se
mettre de côté des personnes qui vont
vite quitté les classes de cours on les
voit assez souvent et puis l'a
apparemment jetée un train discuté avec
quelques élèves qui m'ont fait qu'ils
m'ont prévenu qu'ils avaient tous subi
du harcèlement et que c'est en train de
subir moi même j'ai été victime de
harcèlement et si on peut éviter à des
élèves
depuis sa situation bas c'est vraiment
important pour moi en tout cas et au
moins avec ses interventions souvent les
élèves se confie à non à l'origine deux
élèves du lycée basque aux lancers en
2018 la team regroupe maintenant une
trentaine de jeunes impliqués ils sont
encadrés par des responsables de
l'établissement c'est eux qui font la
formation auprès des élèves nous adultes
on est là pour les accompagner les
guider c'est pas nous les adultes qui
impose aux informations vraiment c'est
eux qui construisent on les accompagne
on régule on les aide on les guide
certain nombre aujourd'hui dans un
cursus d'études supérieures continue à
sensibiliser blandine est présente
depuis 2018 ludmila depuis 2019 notre
ligne directrice et elle est 6e
aujourd'hui on s'est beaucoup diversifié
notamment au lycée basse quand on fait
des interventions à la demande des
professeurs si on voit on détecte un cas
on préviendra du coup les principales et
c'est à eux d'agir et on n'agit pas
assez pas à nous deux on n'est pas un
règlement de problèmes c'est on avertit
8 heures ce jeudi matin une partie de la
team est sur le pont pour cette journée
nationale de lutte contre le harcèlement
de nombreux rendez vous sont proposés on
a aménagé en jeu du loup garou pour en
faire une chasse à la paix qui permettra
de montrer le principe de harcèlement
donc c'est également de la prévention
montrer le principe du harcèlement au
sein d'un lycée dans une école avec
vraiment le harceleur le harceler les
parents en 2019 le 30 20 plateformes des
deux victimes et aux parents a été
sollicité près de 80 mille fois
motiver les jeunes dans leur insertion
professionnelle quoi de mieux qu'une
championne pour le faire et témoigner de
son parcours la médaillée de bronze aux
jeux paralympiques margot boulet
médaillé en aviron est venu participer à
une rencontre c'était hier au centre
commercial westfield et vélizy 2 et ce
dans le cadre du programme scola porté
par les apprentis d'auteuil on me dit
dans l'oreillette que nous n'avons pas
le reportage on vous proposera peut-être
ce reportage d'ici la fin de cette
édition en attendant depuis 25 ans pour
un sourire d'enfant agi pour sauver les
enfants de la misère et de la
maltraitance au cambodge fondatrice de
l'association marie france des pallières
a écrit un livre qui porte le même nom
que l'association elle était en dédicace
était le week-end dernier à la librairie
et des lacs au vésinet le reportage de
mélanie poquet de célia 400 go
25 ans d'une association résumer en
quatre cents pages pour un sourire
d'enfant raconte l'histoire de cette
association humanitaire fondée par un
couple marie france et christian des
pallières tout jeune retraité ils se
rendent au cambodge à phnom penh en 1995
là bas ils découvrent une décharge à
ciel ouvert où des centaines d'enfants y
travaille on s'est dit on peut pas
laisser ça il faut faire quelque chose
on a commencé petit à petit un pas
devant l'autre sens avant ou en haleine
mené 10 à cette époque là où on en
serait aujourd'hui je me dis attendez
vous êtes fous on a un fait que c'est de
répondre aux besoins au fur à mesure
qu'ils se présentaient tout bêtement
marie-france des pallières a donc voulu
coucher par écrit ses mémoires
elle était en dédicace à la librairie
des lacs au vésinet l'association compte
désormais quatre écoles qui regroupe 21
une formation six mille cinq cents
enfants qui sont scolarisés dans les
programmes et 5500 enfants qui ont pu
trouver un métier l'engagement est en
forme et auquel on tient qui est de les
accompagner jusqu'à un métier et donc ça
passe par rapport à paj scolaire pour
ceux qui ont trois quatre cinq années de
retard ceux qui n'ont pas trop de retard
et sont scolarisés en écoles publiques
ont fourni aux familles de
de quoi compenser le manque à gagner de
ce que l'enfant ne rapporte plus en
travaillant la fondatrice de
l'association restera six mois en france
l'occasion de découvrir ses lecteurs qui
sont généralement aussi donateurs de
l'association s'est très
c'est très
oui c'est très émouvant de les
rencontrer tous ceux qu'on a vus là-bas
ici enfin qui ont fait des choses qui
nous suivent sur mercredi 8 décembre
marie france des pallières sera en
dédicace à la librairie gibert joseph à
versailles
et on termine donc avec cette rencontre
en présence de margaux boulet médaillé
de bronze aux jeux paralympiques de
tokyo en aviron elle est allée à la
rencontre de jeunes du programme scola
le programme scola est porté par les
apprentis d'auteuil et cette réunion
pour inciter les jeunes dans leur
insertion professionnelle s'est déroulée
hier mercredi c'était au centre
commercial westfield vélizy 2 le
reportage de mathilde de franco
victime d'une grave blessure à la
cheville et au dos lors d'un saut en
parachute lorsqu'elle était au gign
margot boulet a su faire preuve de
résilience lors des jeux paralympiques
de tokyo elle a décroché la médaille de
bronze en aviron elle était présente
mercredi 17 novembre au centre ouest
field vélizy 2 pour présenter son
parcours en tant que marraine du
programme scola quand on a proposé en
fait de parrainer cette à cette
promotion qu'on a expliqué le concept
ans j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait un certain
parallèle entre mon parcours l'accident
ait cette chance que j'ai eue de pouvoir
rebondir
c'est une chanson qu'on m'a proposé je
suis pas arrivé tout seul est ce qu'on
la perd mais aussi à ça c'est jeune et
j'ai trouvé que c'était très beau
c'était à la fois aux et audacieux j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup à passer le concept
j'étais disponible donc j'étais ravi de
voir venir le programme scola porté par
les apprentis d'auteuil permet à des
jeunes peu ou non diplômés d'accéder à
l'emploi sur des secteurs en tension
comme la vente pendant deux heures ils
ont pu échanger et présenter leurs
boutiques à margaux boulet un moment
enrichissant des deux côtés ça ne peut
que malgré un environnement qu'un
accident qu'elle a eue
c'est elle a continué elle est devenue
championne
ceinture que tout est possible d'autant
que j'ai pas eu d'accident suis en forme
c'est à dire que j'ai toutes les chances
de
réussir juste il faut croire en soi de
vous le voir terminer s'inspire ans j'ai
dit j'ai discuté avec les stagiaires et
sarah donner du jus de l'espoir
donc c'est important d'avoir des gens
comme ça vraiment tout est possible tant
qu'on ait envie un message fort que
margot boulet souhaité délivrer aux
stagiaires du programme scola de quoi
les rebooster pour réussir leurs examens
de fin d'année et se fixer de nouveaux
objectifs
le reportage avec la voix de nicolas
d'andry bien sûr voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité
demain place aux 7,8 week-end de
l'actualité et des idées de sorties pour
bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]